it was an exceptional person but
probably more exceptional than I
realized
you know before this happened he was
very privileged in lots of ways you know
he grew up in a good home a stable
family materially quite comfortable and
he could see the contrast between how he
had experienced life and how lot of
these prisoners had experienced their
their lives and he felt very lucky can I
ask you how you found out mmm that it
was your son that had been doing this
yeah so I had seen reports on Twitter
from about 2:00 o'clock that day that
there had been an incident at London
Bridge I didn't know jack was at London
Bridge that day I didn't really think
much of it other than I don't know
there's been another attack out you know
terrible when I got home my wife was
driving my car into the drive which
seemed to be odd and she came out I'd
been listening to a podcast on my
headphones and she was just beside
herself saying we've got to go to London
I've got to go to London and I said why
I've got to go to London and she said
because Jack has been involved in this
incident a London Bridge I said okay how
do you know and she said because the an
has phoned me and she's been contacted
by somebody and we think he's been
stamped we got to London
we got a taxi went to the Royal London
Hospital and waited and then we were
told at about quarter to 11:00 that they
confirmed that he had been killed so
that was how we found out
and when we got to back to Cambridge we
had to go meet our son he'd been working
I've been having a drink with his
friends in the pub in Cambridge and we
had to get him out of the pub and tell
him he didn't know they didn't know we
didn't want to tell him over the phone
we didn't want anybody else to tell him
so we went and got him don't we had to
tell him his brother had died which was
probably the hardest thing I had to do
so far the natural reaction also might
be to be really angry because you've
just lost your child doing the most
horrific circumstances do you feel angry
about it don't feel angry about what
happened I feel bereft and very very sad
did he know what went on he did in yours
ammonia yep you knew him does it bother
you the idea that John knew him does
that make it worse in your mind is
somehow that they had a relationship and
then this happened to your child and it
makes it more unbelievable because again
I can't I can't imagine how someone who
had been befriended and helped by
someone like Jack could then in a very
fairly calculating way kill them the
only person responsible for what he did
is him so I'm not gonna start lashing
out saying somebody should have stopped
this somebody must be responsible for
this
the police family liaison people advised
us not to do anything on social media I
look Tom I know I suppose I shouldn't
have done I looked on Twitter on the
Saturday morning and already there was
discussion about what happened and what
it meant and
some political reaction immediately
people start jumping on the
criminal-justice bandwagon so you know
advocating longer sentences and harsher
penalties and I knew how passionate was
about rehabilitation and helping people
to redeem themselves and I could already
see it starting to move in the opposite
direction but I just thought it was
important to just push back against that
narrative you had seen that the Prime
Minister had made a statement about
being against slowly release that story
began to build yeah over the weekend
yeah what was required was just you know
dignified a dignified approach you know
whereby the politicians would you know
express their regrets express their
condolences to the to the people
affected and would then get on with
campaigning in the election it wasn't an
election issue where most of us will
were watching this and seeing a tragedy
unfolding in front of our eyes instead
of seeing a tragedy Boris Johnson saw an
opportunity and he went on the offensive
he saw an opportunity to score some
points in the election he immediately
said oh this is Labour's fault they they
you know they allowed this to happen
they had this early release policy and
so on and at that point it was just well
I had to say something so he he went on
the offensive yes your son we've just
lost him only you office he found it
very offensive you found him very
offensive I did I did there was no
reference to us you know there was no
attempt to contact us and and discuss
this with us or with anybody else as far
as I know did you have any contact from
the prime minister from number turn
about Jack but now what you deserved
about sentencing no no I think never the
the only contact we had was that the the
police liaison officer said to us I've
been asked if you would like to meet
Priti Patel for her to express her
condolences and we just said no thank
you
there was a beautiful picture of Jack on
the front of all the papers oh really
he was graduates and wasn't here long
picture yeah and then next to it was
obviously the headlines about changing
the prison sentence and that was the the
article that the prime minister written
in the merlin how did you feel when you
saw your son's picture juxtaposed with
that um pretty much as you would expect
it just reinforced my views and my
feelings about the way in which this
situation was being exploited it just
struck me as being crass and insensitive
and as we've already said Jack would
have been extremely upset at the way in
which things were developing but some
people said that you've also politicized
your son's death because you don't like
Forrest Ronson very much what do you say
to that I would say that if anybody has
a right to say something about this
situation then it's me and his family
you know we have lost jack jack can't
speak for himself anymore had there been
no comment in the way that it was made
then I wouldn't have said anything you
know I would have just carried on
grieving and and helping to support my
family I think the way that it happened
and the fact that it was used in such a
political way and I could see
the good work that Jack did and that his
colleagues did starting to perhaps
unravel it was important that somebody
said something and that just happened to
be me and obviously my son's being
killed people are going to listen to me